we're going to prove this result about
prime numbers
and powers of two and this is a really
cute sort of question because
the particular content of the question
actually has some really interesting
historical implications
uh for mathematics and uh and its
development over the century so let's
have a look
prove that if 2 to the n minus 1 is
prime then
n is prime by proving the contrapositive
okay let's think about this for a second
for starters
the reason why i said this is a cute
question is that 2 to the n
minus 1 this is not just some random
result
2 to the n minus 1 obviously it's an odd
number because
2 to the n is always going to be even
but 2 to the n
minus 1 often is a prime number it's not
just any prime
it's what we call a mercen prime named
after a french
mathematician who discovered that this
was a nice and convenient way to develop
or to find prime numbers particularly
very large ones you know when things are
off to an exponential they grow super
fast uh in fact
um all of the largest prime numbers that
we've discovered you know numbers that
go for hundreds and hundreds
of digits um that you know
supercomputers are crunching through and
trying to calculate is this thing prime
is it is it composite or whatever
all of the large primes that we know
about they're all of this form they are
all
mercen prime so that's why this is not
just uh you know
something we can prove by the
contrapositive it is also it is also
having
historical value how do we prove this
well because
the question has given us this kind of
well a pretty heavy node right
use the contrapositive what i have to
say is how do i
get the contrapositive out of this
statement and then i will try and prove
that directly
so you can see here if 2 to the n
minus 1 is prime so 2 to the n minus 1
is prime
is the first half it's the antecedent
clause or statement within this
implication
i'm going to negate that and put it
rounded at the beginning i'm going to
put the end
and then you've got this second half the
consequent statement
then n is prime so i'm going to negate
that as well
and put it at the beginning so how do i
state that
i can say this is the contrapositive so
i'm just going to write
that here the contrapositive
not q implies not
p in this particular question is
if n is not prime
just very simply negating it then
here comes not p then to the n
minus 1 is not prime
now i did say it did slip in a little
bit before i did um you might want to
say the word composite here right but we
do know there are numbers that are
neither prime
nor composite uh numbers like one zero
weirdos like that
uh they are of course very important
numbers for not sitting in these
categories but that's why
i can't say if n is composite and then 2
to the n minus 1 is composite that's not
the full negation i need the exact
opposite of the statement that we began
with statements in fact
how do we go about this well i want to
think about if n is not
prime what can i like this is what i'm
required to prove
uh what can i say about it well it's to
do with factorization right so what i
can say is
uh let this number n let it be
factorized into
i mean who knows how many factors uh it
has but it's gonna have at least
two that are not uh that are not going
to be one so i can say
um n equals say a times b
where a and b they both need to be whole
numbers
a and b are whole numbers and of course
if a
or b were one then uh that would be a
problem right because then i could say
oh
uh what if n was 1 times 11
does that count and the answer is no of
course uh 1 times 11 is 11.
11 is is prime so i have to say i have
to respect even further
um and a and b cannot equal
1. so here's my groundwork what can i do
with this well i want to prove that if n
is not prime if n
can be written like this then 2 to the n
minus 1 is also
not prime so in other words i can say
2 to the power of n minus 1 equals
2 to the power of a b minus 1.
then you might think i'm stuck because
there's not much that it looks like you
can do with this thing
i want to prove that this thing is not
prime but it doesn't look like there's
any obvious
like manipulation you could do to it if
you were being asked to simplify
and you had some expression or some
function and this was the last line that
you ended up with i think most of us
would say
i'm pretty happy with that it is as
simple as it gets
so where do i go next there are no
obvious steps
well it is kind of true that this is as
simple as it gets we need to
complicate this object in order to prove
what we want
to prove and to help you sort of see
what's going on here
i want you to remember let me use this
highlighter but what does it mean for
2 to the n minus 1 to not be prime well
it's very similar to
n not being prime i need to be able to
write some kind of factorization i need
to be able to say
that this this term here or expression
rather
i should be able to write it as
something times something else
where neither of those things is one if
if neither of them are one
and they're whole numbers then well
there's a factorization so it's not
going to be primes that's where i need
to
head to how can i factorize this thing
um how can i work with this term here
and come up with something factorizable
is that a word
composite i guess to show that this is a
factorizable
object i want to think well what objects
vaguely
look like this that i do know how to
factorize
now you can see from the start here
you've got this term here it's got an
index it's got it the whole thing is a
power and then you take away one
i actually do know how to factorize a
bunch of things that are somewhat in
that format
something raised to a power minus one
the simplest one that we know about we
learned about years ago
we would call it the difference of
squares but this is a particular
difference of squares
not just a squared minus b squared but
take away one this is really easy to
factorize in fact
it's just x minus one x
plus one that's great now the only
problem with using this result is that
it relies on the fact that the index
here is 2 and
i don't know what this index is it's not
going to be 2 it's going to be some
non-prime number so i need to go from
this to something something larger and
more complicated so
let's see if we can establish a pattern
of factorization that can help us
following this pattern to work with this
object up here
let's consider a higher power because
i'm going
in the direction of 2 to the power of a
b and a b
i know as a non-prime number is going to
be a bit bigger than this
what's the factorization x cubed minus 1
now you might know this one
this is a difference of cubed it's
actually remarkably similar
to the factorization for difference of
squares it's x minus 1 and then
x squared plus x plus 1. you could
expand this out to contain yourself if
you haven't seen this result before
if you just multiply and distribute
through everything by x you'd get x
cubed plus x squared plus x x cubed plus
x
squared plus x i might as well write
that down x cubed plus
x squared plus x and then when you
distribute the minus 1
you're going to get minus x squared
minus x minus
1. so you can see the x squareds cancel
the x's cancel and that just leaves you
with the x cubed and the minus 1
just like you wanted so this is actually
really neat and you can continue
this pattern it's actually something
which is very useful when you're
deriving the power rule for
differentiating x to the power of n
that's the objects that i've got here
right
i can say x to the 4 minus 1 i just want
to establish the pattern here
it's going to start with an x minus 1
and then it's going to go x cubed
x squared all of the x terms all the way
down to
1. so i want to try and get to
something like this this a b right well
if i go up to say
and you'll see why i'm choosing this in
a second if i go up to some arbitrary
uh positive integer like b right
i'm going to get x to the minus x to the
b minus 1 equals right how does it begin
well
continuing the pattern they all begin
with x minus 1 right so
you're going to have the x minus 1 out
the front and then what you get is this
it's this long polynomial that has 1 and
x and x squared all the way up to
this largest power where that largest
power is always just look at it
carefully
one less whoa that was much bigger than
i anticipated
uh one less than the power that you
started with you can see i've got
two where i had three and then even
though it's not written there you can
see there's a one hiding here
and there's a two so you can see i'm
going to go from 1
to x to x squared and i'm going to
terminate on the power of x just one
less than what's in my original
expression so what's one less than b
it's b minus 1. so i'm going to go b
minus 1
and then i'm going to have one less than
that which i guess would be b minus 2
continue the pattern b minus 3 and it
keeps going until you finish
on 1 which you can see in all of these
factorizations up above here now
how does this help me well think about
this
right think about how this is related to
this object that we have
up here and i'm going to name this i'm
going to call this equation 1 so that i
can
work with it i can say well if i
substitute
instead of x if i put in 2 to the power
of a
in there then what i'm going to have
here on the left-hand side is 2 to the
power of
a b so i'm just going to go ahead and
write 2 to the power of a
that's my chosen x to the power of b
minus 1 equals all right everywhere that
i had x i'm just going to substitute it
for
2 to the power of a so let's have a go 2
to the power of a
minus 1. and then what have i got here
maybe i'll draw a bigger bracket so i
can fit in my to the power of a
to the b minus one to the power of a
again
to the b minus two um one more time
to complete the pattern b minus three
and then dot dot all the way
to one all right so what have i got here
well
on my left hand side this is where i
left off in equation one right this was
that object where i was like i don't
know what to do with this thing well
now i do know what to do with this thing
i can say
well i've got this factorization written
here on the right hand side so i can say
uh substitute this result into
one
uh 2 to the n minus 1. instead of
writing it as
2 to the a b minus 1 i'm going to take
everything here
and duplicate that down so where does
this leave me i mean it's a
factorization but we already established
that
just because you have um something times
something that doesn't mean that you're
going to have
a non-prime number one of those two
factors might be one so 1 times 11
doesn't mean that 11 is non-prime so i
need to show
that neither of these two things this
object and this object neither of them
can be equal to one how do i do that
well for starters you can see let's deal
with this one over here on the right
hand side
this can't possibly equal to one because
you can see
there's a one right there and then
you're adding things to it right
all of these things that are added to
one mean you're going to be bigger than
one so i can say
uh let's i'll just leave those arrows
there that's fine
everything in here that can't equal
1. well that leaves me with this object
on the left hand side
think about this 2 to the n minus 1
it can equal 1 under certain
circumstances but we actually know
that that's not the case because of a
restriction that we placed on a
right at the very beginning you can see
over here
a and b they can't be 1 right so
therefore
i can say if a can't be 1
then 2 to the power of a can't possibly
be 2 to the power of 1
which is 2 and that means 2 to the a
minus 1
that can't possibly be 2 minus 1 which
is 1.
so you can see i've just you know used
this
raised it to the power of the previous
line and then i've subtracted 1 from
both sides to land
on this so therefore i can say therefore
2 to the n minus 1 is not
prime which is exactly what i was
setting out to prove
in the contrapositive right here
so i started with this i proved that
this was the case
i'm pretty much finished all i need to
say at the very end is uh
by you could either say by the law of
the contra positive
or by contra position is another concise
way of saying which is also equivalent i
can say
if 2 to the n
minus 1 is prime
then n must be prime
and there's that proof of that lovely
result about miss sen primes